hallo wir sind heute in der staatlichen
musikschule in katowice frau wasser hat
uns in ihren deutsch unterricht
eingeladen unser heutiges thema ist
musik wer ist das das ist ein fauler
spieler
china ist ein komponist er hat viele
berühmte filmmusik komponiert zum
beispiel dracula das ist ein konzert war
was machen sie viel
wir sitzen im konzertsaal
die schüler spielen regelmäßig konzerte
im konzertsaal werk welches instrument
spielst du ich spiele klavier
[Musik]
xamax spielt auf dem konzertflügel der
schule die schüler geben applaus jetzt
sind sie in der orgelklasse marius lernt
hier orgelspielen marius was ist das das
ist eine pfeife
diese orgel hat 400 pfeifen sie hat 112
tasten und 20 pedale marius kannst du
für und orgel spielen
marius was ist das das wird die noten
ein notenblatt eine orgel besteht aus
drei teilen
eine für die linke hand eine für die
rechte hand und eine für die füße an
deck welches instrument spielst du ich
spiele gitarre
das ist eine klassische gitarre
im unterschied zu einer elektrischen
gitarre die gitarre hat sechs
verschiedene seiten und man spielt in
verschiedenen bündeln kannst du etwas
gitarre für uns spielen natürlich jetzt
sind wir in der klasse schlaginstrument
wird mac und matthäus die bienen auf der
marimba das niemals machen
jetzt sind sie im schlagzeug olaf spielt
schlagzeug
das war unser video aus der musikschule
wir hoffen es hat euch gefallen
[Musik]